let's talk plans for diane's baby shower
dear god woman three main activities
baby bingo baby food tasting and my
personal favorite baby onesie decorating
station i'm gonna make mine look like an
astronaut what are you doing up there in
space baby oh so cute okay i have some
gift ideas i was looking at a very
adorable stroller we already have a
stroller oh shoot really i have to think
of something else
oh my god whose baby is that that would
be mine guys get in here run as a baby
oh ron cool maybe thank you andrew
everyone i'd like to introduce you to my
son
john middle name redacted swanson john
was born some time ago weighing multiple
pounds and several ounces much like his
father he is a fan of silence please
keep your voices down how am i supposed
to keep my voice down when you had your
baby and you didn't tell me that you
hate your baby why would you need to
know something like that why would i oh
my god
i have not even sent diana gift she's
just walking around wondering why i
haven't sent her a gift yet should we do
something just let her tire herself out
if you need anything from us around
please just let us know actually there
is something could one of you please
stop by the pet store and pick up some
fish food for me
when did you get a fish
oh my god you're so cute you're the
cutest little blueberry i've ever seen
you are the world's most adorable baby
and i love you you are so freaking
precious
the cook ale made for the baby it says
property of pawnee government isn't that
adorable
come on john
mouse rat cd 30
candy bars 50
50
god people here are so cheap april where
have you been over two phone calls came
in unimpeded we're raising money for my
college education ron
i took a second job back at my old job
do you want a shoeshine it's a hundred
dollars
laugh all you want kyle i already took
the money out of your wallet
oh
good news son
you have just won
a ron swanson scholarship
i don't think so i don't remember
applying for anything andy ron swanson
scholarship
wait are you serious
stop this
no
i stop or you lose the money
why not
i like the kid and i have the money
one thing i promised myself when i
buried gold in my backyard was that i'd
never be a hoarder or a miser about it
hey hey am i interrupting something
important impossible i work for the
government i just picked up the girls
thought we'd stop by or the girls
yes they are hello girls
diane and i have been seeing a lot of
each other recently she is a sharp
confident strong woman her children are
loud
[Applause]
this is fun easy girls we'll be careful
miss lewis
i'm sorry
we just wanted to invite you to come
trick-or-treating tonight i think i'm a
little old can we go wrong please please
oh you can kill i'm sure we have to go
buy seven or else good can you'll be
gone
sounds perfect
come on girls
what the hell just happened
in the time i've worked here i've taken
great pains to see as little of this
building as possible turns out the third
floor is silent empty and completely
free of government work
i can't think of anything more beautiful
to share with my son
if i had a toolbox i could take care of
that faulty radiator
this place is a paradise just as we
suspected john we repaired the valve
stem seal and now all that remains is to
tighten down this packing nut
and that should do it can we help you
no we have everything under control my
crew's redoing this whole floor we're
the only people allowed up here right
now we'll proceed with your work you
won't notice us at all well
we're gonna be kind of loud
my son is several weeks old he's quite
familiar with the sound of power tools
hmm
your shoes are red now yay hooray
hey mommy
you survived huh indeed i did
how were they really couldn't have been
better
we had a wonderful time oh that's good
cause my sitter is still out of town
so i
really hate to ask you this but is there
any way that you could take him again
tomorrow no of course i'd be delighted
you're a lifesaver
thank you girls you want to spend
another day with ron yeah
ben is meeting with the tent people to
finalize those deals april and donna
will be helping me with the vendor
location charts and i will be meeting
with the surveyors about the concert
grounds i would like to volunteer to do
the park survey myself wow ron i always
knew there would be a day when i would
get through to you and you would love
government work today is that historic
day yes that is what has happened
spending the day outside alone sounds
like a dream
i love being a father but there are a
few things i miss silence the absence of
noise
one single moment undisturbed by the
sounds of a children's tv program called
doc mcstuffins
there is no quiet anymore
there is only doc mcstuffins
hey what's up guys look what ron made
it's amazing several months ago i was on
a walk and found my crib tree
i approached the tree murdered it left
it to cure in my wood shop and have
begun working it into a crib for my
upcoming child ron swanson
you cannot use this crib you're ignoring
every known crib safety standard it's
all covered in the parenting book i'm
reading are you going to crawl my way by
lenny kravitz my crib will be safe
because i'm building it with my own two
hands thank you for the woodworking
lesson ron this whole crib recall things
got me literally rethinking everything i
thought i knew about parenting what
sleep method will you be using
ferber sears
swanson method where you close your eyes
and fall asleep i really wish ron would
engage but he exudes so much wisdom that
i can learn parenting tips simply by
being in his presence someone like ron
is teaching
even when they're not teaching does that
make sense
my anxiety has kept me up
for over 50 hours
if a joint is properly fashioned all you
need to do is guide it into place
all you need to do is guide it into
place what i get from that is when
parenting sometimes a subtle hand is
more effective than a strong one
this is already so much more helpful
than the last book of parenting i read
rad dads by apollo anton ono and sean
white
[Music]
ron why did you throw that wood away
it's unstable it's no good i just don't
understand the throwing away the wood
metaphor
what's the lesson oh i know
it's potty training that trash can is
the toilet and the wood was the feces
chris i'm not teaching you anything
we're just building a crib no i know
you're not consciously teaching me
anything i'm just trying to siphon off
some of your calm centered wisdom
through metaphors metaphors i hate
metaphors that's why my favorite book is
moby dick
no frou-frou symbolism just a good
simple tale about a man who hates an
animal that's enough for today i think
an organized child no
ron what's this the crib i built
i'm giving it to you and anne it's
perfectly safe i tested it by hitting it
with my truck well ron i can't accept
this is for your baby there's more than
one crib tree in a forest that's not a
lesson by the way just a comment on
lumber availability
it's beautiful thank you nobody has all
the right answers in parenting including
me and that toxic crib you bought won't
be the last mistake you make but a man
who is this worried about making all the
right choices
cares very much
that's all that matters you'll be a
great father
thank you ron
for the crib and the advice it's much
better than any metaphor
clear my throat
oh look john it's red pine
they were gonna put flecked linoleum
over this beautifully preserved naughty
red pine most people in this world john
are asked
this is the best day i've ever spent in
a government building and luckily my son
was here to share it with me he now has
that satisfied look that only comes with
the pride of labor
or he pooped
either way well done john
you